[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Centroamérica desde
Guatemala donde el próximo 25 de junio 9
millones 300.000 guatemaltecos
habilitados votarán para elegir
presidente vicepresidente diputados al
congreso diputados al parlamento
centroamericano alcaldes y gobernadores
unos comicios en los que dos mujeres
protagonizan la carrera hacia la
presidencia de la República Suri ríos y
Sandra Torres son de las candidatas con
mayor opción para suceder en el cargo al
actual mandatario Alejandro yamatei
sur y ríos es hija del fallecido
dictador de Guatemala Efraín Ríos montt
la hija del General golpista actualmente
candidata por el partido valor unionista
fue diputada en cuatro periodos
legislativos y con esta se ha postulado
tres veces a la presidencia su rival en
las encuestas es la candidata del
partido une Sandra Torres antigua
primera dama de Guatemala del 2008 al
2011 durante la presidencia de Álvaro
Colón Torres se divorció de Colón para
poder aspirar a la presidencia dado que
la ley se lo impedía si seguía casada
con él de esta forma pudo postularse en
2015 y en 2019 y en ambas oportunidades
pasó a segunda vuelta en 2015 perdió la
presidencia contra Jimmy Morales y en
2019 contra Alejandro yamatei para el
actual candidato presidencial hermón
mullet cualquier voto para sur y ríos y
Sandra Torres es un voto para yamatei y
para el continuismo en Guatemala
que no me Vengan ahora a decir de que
son niñas de Primera Comunión y que no
tienen nada que ver con eso Por supuesto
que eso corresponsables de la corrupción
son corresponsables de la falta de
trabajo de oportunidades de procesos de
de desinstitucionalización que llevamos
son corresponsables de todo lo que
Guatemala está sufriendo en este momento
edmon mulet es el otro candidato que se
ubica en los primeros puestos según
varios sondeos de medios de comunicación
mullet fue diputado por 12 años
presidente del Congreso subsecretario
general de las Naciones Unidas embajador
de Guatemala en Washington y en la Unión
Europea desde el partido cabal que
representa mulet trae una propuesta
anticorrupción de Centro derecha y la
corrupción está en las municipalidades
está en el ejército está en la policía
está en el sistema judicial está en
todas partes en el en los partidos
políticos O sea que es una estamos
infectados de eso y estamos en una etapa
como sociedad como República en una
etapa muy difícil que yo he visto en
muchos otros países del mundo que es la
etapa del
sálvese quien pueda
el candidato edmon mulet no se ha
salvado de una denominada persecución
judicial en Guatemala recientemente la
fiscalía especial contra la impunidad lo
relacionó en una presunta conspiración
de obstrucción de justicia en el caso
del reconocido periodista guatemalteco
encarcelado José Rubén Zamora
otra de las polémicas decisiones
judiciales en el marco de estos comicios
presidenciales afectó a la Popular líder
indígena Telma Cabrera quien
postulándose por el partido movimiento
para la liberación de los pueblos tuvo
que resignarse hacerse a un lado a ser
cancelada de esta contienda electoral
no es por falta de requisitos es el
miedo que tiene el sistema que se le cae
los privilegios y se desata toda la
impunidad que ha hecho en contra de
Defensores y defensoras presos políticos
aquí en Guatemala eso es la verdadera
razón pero a nosotros no nos quita el
sueño a mí no me quita el sueño
inscriben o no inscriben Yo estoy mi
lucha es de diario nuestras luchas con
los pueblos es constantemente y entonces
no
O sea no termina en el momento electoral
en las pasadas elecciones presidenciales
Thelma Cabrera participó como candidata
y alcanzó un cuarto lugar pero en estas
de 2023 su candidatura fue rechazada por
el tribunal supremo electoral tras una
razón administrativa que empañó a su
fórmula vicepresidencial el exprocurador
de los Derechos Humanos Jordán Rodas
para muchos expertos El Binomio de
Thelma Cabrera y Jordán Rodas representa
un Dúo anticorrupción capaz de tambalear
el establecimiento político motivo por
el cual muchos aseguran que su exclusión
por parte del supremo electoral fue
arbitraria sin embargo el órgano se
defiende y se apoya en la ley
Es evidente que al no ser inscrito a
alguien puede generar un tipo de duda
que tiene los recursos legales para ser
resueltos Y por supuesto la comunidad
internacional puede ser una ventana de
oportunidad para algún tipo de denuncia
pero estamos seguros que el pleno ha
hecho lo que le toca hacer a la luz de
la ley de electoral de partidos
políticos y la constitución política de
la República de Guatemala
el clima electoral en Guatemala se tensa
cada vez más con la publicación de
diferentes encuestas y sondeos pero
ninguno de ellos En donde se vea una
mayoría Clara para algunos de los
candidatos por lo que se presume que
Habrá segunda vuelta presidencial
programada para el mes de agosto así
terminamos esta misión de enlace
Centroamérica en la cámara estuvo mi
colega Aurora recuerde que este capítulo
lo pueden encontrar en nuestro sitio web
trans24.com hasta una próxima